heißt es heißt es dann das dass du meine
mutter ist heute hat sie kommen zu einem
neuen video hat sicherlich an dem hilfe
logo und familie schon erkannt dass hier
wird kein angenehmes video und zwar habe
ich als ich ein bisschen gestöbert habe
unter anderem auch auf den hilf mir
kanal mal wieder abgecheckt und guckt
was also passiert und da ist mir als als
oberstes video direkt ans vorgeschlagen
worden
ja also die ersten zehn sekunden gesehen
weil diese automatisch abstimmungen auf
dem kanal ist und da war schon klar okay
das müssen wir auseinander nehmen da
führt kein weg daran vorbei die rede ist
von der absolut legendären meisterlichen
produktionen familien mix up meine
schwester ist eigentlich meine mutter ja
lass uns mal durch den kopf gehen
das ist wieder so ein scheiß da kommt
auch wieder die hilf mir daraufhin ja
ich würde sagen wir schon mal
reinschauen was es damit auf sich hat
[Gelächter]
das ist doch wieder schon so ein
haarsträubender unsinn leute ohne witz
okay also analysieren wie das ganz kurz
mal junges mädchen läuft lange sagt er
ist mein 17
geburtstag keine einzige wunsch ist zu
wissen wer mein vater ist und das ist ja
auch wirklich also muss ich so sagen ich
wäre nicht parteiisch sein aber das ist
wunsch kann man schon nachvollziehen
den kann man tatsächlich nachvollziehen
ihre mutter hätte hinterher hört den
wunsch ihrer tochter das so sage ich
nicht der wasserzins gerade gesagt hat
sie gesagt dann schmeiße ich mich vor so
auto typ und legt auf die straße gut
gute strategie man sich sagen an der
stelle hatte schon kurz die beschreibung
google heißt nicht dass es relevant wäre
okay die tochter ist ja die mutter heißt
kathrin von cd hat sich gedacht okay gut
wenn ich den namen meines vaters nicht
erfahre
dann lasse mich eben vom auto überfahren
das ist ne gute herangehensweise wird
nicht nur eine gute strategie
beim aufstehen habe ich gesagt was ihr
denn völlig bescheuert männer waren
wieso kann nicht mehr so der normale
interaktion mit zum radfahrer irgendwie
also halbwegs authentisch wirken wir
müssen aber auch verständnis haben für
den fahrradfahrer leute hier schauen wir
noch mal in dieser situation ganz genau
rein
ja weil ich meine ja ich habe sie keine
möglichkeit da vorbeizufahren
also es ist ja nicht so als wenn da
rechts und links jeweils drei meter
platz
der saal gruyter kollege ganz im ernst
ich weiß ich erst mal die falsch
gelaufen ist an dem tag aber halt
einfach an denen vorbei so absolut
erfreulich leute ist unter aller sau was
was soll der mist stell dich nicht so an
als ob wir jetzt sagen wir der leibliche
vater ist
was soll der unsinn denn natürlich warum
streitet man was wir nicht wissen will
endlich wissen wer mein vater ist das
bin ich in mamas kiste verfassen
naja ok ok das macht das jetzt wieder
sind also ich muss sagen bisher die
folge war sie erst mal relativ unsinnig
wieder überraschender weise aber die
kiste verflossenen liebhaber das ist
natürlich etwas was jede mutter in
deutschland was sagen ihre mutter was
jeder mensch in deutschland natürlich im
schrank hat bisher sei gesagt dass wir
das so ein mystisches seite versteht ja
wieso bei herr der ringe oder so oder
bei harry potter aber vor so neue harry
potter teil harry potter die kiste
verflossenen liebhaber
was ist denn mit dir du hast du den
ganzen tag im rasen kosten sind die
kamera was also es würde mich nicht
würde mich das nicht überraschen wenn
jetzt einfach am ende der folge so ein
typ im hasenkostüm der vater ist
ich glaube schocken würde uns selbst das
nicht mehr aber leute mit blick auf die
titel der folge meine schwester ist
eigentlich meine mutter am können wir
eigentlich schon abschätzen bei rtl2
immer nur vier darsteller vierte folge
buch das die person die auf der linken
scheinbar die mutter von der auf der
rechten ist also wenn dieser links die
mutter von der rechts das wäre es dann
die frau am anfang
der vater ist dass der vater das würde
sinn machen digger schwester ist die
mutter und dann ist eine rolle freiheit
dann ist die mutter der vater der ja was
war das alter egal ich den übelsten
playboy ich hab's euch gesagt heute mit
der kiste verflossenen liebhaber es
nicht zu spaßen der der ist richtiger
playboy jähriger der mit der orangen
brille
das sind wir dem los ist das nicht schon
unser paketbote ja jetzt auch wieder so
was ist das jetzt wieder für eine
unsinnige heißt also erst mal ob ich die
kiste verflossener liebhaber ja wir
kennen sie alle weit verbreitet in
deutschland
ganz im ernst hat hat ihre mutter den iq
von der amöbe welcher normale mensch
selbst wenn er eine kiste verflossener
die papa hat okay dann einfach ein bild
vom postboten rein so wie dumm kann man
seinem wahnsinn das hat man uns nie
erzählt dass sie den schon so lange
kennt das kannst du mir glauben
von mir aus wenn dafür dass wenn mein
vater ist noch so eine lebensmüde aktion
wie gerade eben lebensmüde ja ich glaube
sie meint die stelle wo sie hier sie auf
den boden gelegt hat und typ gemacht hat
lebensmittel und dann kam ein
fahrradfahrer angeschossen und er konnte
einfach nicht mehr ausweichen
der hat einfach gleich links und rechts
die 30 meter platz übersehen die kuchen
gerne
die strafbank so geht's dir denn ja gut
und weil jesus kann nicht klagen die
geht zu weit
okay wer ist er jetzt nur weil du dich
[Gelächter]
entwickelt die kommentare so etwas hier
niemand hilft mir meine technik zuerst
wird ist eigentlich mein opa ist 11
dass sie zusammenfassen okay aber wird
uns der mal vorgestellt hier was ist was
das für morgen etwa zwei fingern was
soll der scheiß ist doch sind doch keine
umgangsform kommt einfach zum titel
reichen und wird dann so tiefgründige
gespräche mit der jungen dame hier wie
papierkram ja kenne ich nur oh shit
hast du auch schon mal ein vertrag
unterschrieben und emblemen war
wahnsinnig auch bruder dieser ohrring
ist ja auch bernd sie fällt ganz
wertvoller ich mein wenn man mit so
einem ohrring vor unserer haustür stellt
wer will den nicht einlassen
danke für den kuchen mit sehr gut
geschmeckt aber ich muss wieder los tut
mir leid das geschenk ja was mache ich
jetzt damit
was könnte das sein leute was kann
dieses geschenk sein also rein von der
größe her könnte könnte theoretisch noch
eine eine kiste verflossener die partner
sein ok hab gar zum kleinen abschnitt
übersprungen wollte der typ beim
rausgehen aber was mit der mutter
lammert die haben schon eine beziehung
aber er ist verheiratet war hielt mir
ist egal so er geht mit kappe auf dem
kopf raus okay und jetzt kommt die
nächste szene wie sie hier auf einmal
liegt die kappe da der typ hat ihn zwar
gerade auf dem kopf es ausgegangen ist
aber sie liegt immer noch im haus auf
einmal und cembalist die kappe die
letzte chance
okay was ist mit was mithilfe los ohne
scheiß habt ihr das gehört achtet man
auf den ton ich hab nichts verstellt ich
hab ja eben schon gecheckt an meinem
computer ist auch nichts der ton ist auf
einmal weg beziehen also nicht weg
sondern ist einfach so leise und man
versteht gar nicht mehr so mancher
unterboden kerzen
das hört man auch noch jetzt achtet auch
sie wären da nicht seine lautstärke
stabil produziert er ist weil das ist
wirklich da hat man schon mal was lange
vor deiner geburt und johnny ist
deswegen nicht dein vater bestimmt nicht
ich denke zwar das gegenteil aber keinen
bock drauf
ach so ist tschechischer seite okay das
ist der postbote aus der kiste
verflossener liebhaber jetzt auch die
ganze sache sind hast du denn so meine
reaktion wenn ich sehe wie meine
schwester ist eigentlich meine mutter
ist eins zu eins passiert da aua geht es
noch okay also sie reiste jetzt haben
wir hier in haar ausfüllen dna-test okay
johnny cash ist nicht mein vater seine
vaterschaft kann zu 100 prozent
ausgeschlossen werden
ja mich gelaufen leute ich meine die
wollen alle verhindern dass er sich noch
mal auf so ein lebensmüder art und weise
mitten in einem verkehrsberuhigten
gebiet was wahrscheinlich andere
abgesperrt ist für dreharbeiten kurz auf
dich auf die straße liegt kann ja keiner
wollen sowas ist lebensgefährlich aber
der typ der postbote das ist aber nicht
ihr vater kathleen die aber ist zu 99 99
prozent meine mutter chance
[Gelächter]
ja warum dieser schott alter okay gut
also wir wissen ihre mutter ist ihre
mutter und der postbote vater aber ihre
schwester ist er ihre mutter oder du
machst einen dna-test ihn da meinten
spinnst du eigentlich ja nicht mit mir
am besten leute wir kennen sie alle die
eltern die einen anschreiben und wenn
man dann im gegenzug auch ein bisschen
lauter wird danach aber was ist denn das
für ein tonfall ist das ist der plot ist
also sie hat irgendwie diese haare für
den dna test hat beim post punkt geklaut
hat auch von irgend einer bürste
scheinbar die haare genommen und das
heißt die bürste von ihrer schwester
duster ist dass der ganze platz ist okay
die alles klar dass acting kind wieder
zu sehen wenn du dein schwarm auf der
straße sieht man ihm einfach hallo sagen
willst ja das ist gerade bei der hilfe -
prinzipiell sehr universell einsetzbar
seit meiner geburt hat mich belogen mit
solchen menschen möchte ich nicht länger
was zu tun haben
von toni kommt toni besucher zur neue
familie schlecht gemacht was soll man
dazu sagen
was soll man dazu noch sagen da ist
einfach abgrundtief schlecht ich würde
sagen heute während die sich eine neue
familie sucht suchen wir uns die grenzen
die wir beim schauen dieses videos
verloren haben und die intelligenz die
dabei flöten gegangen ist es gibt
überall für euch vorstellungsvideo wenn
ihr auf diesem kanal ist natürlich
lasst das war so weit von mir leute ich
küsse rauben bis zum nächsten mal